Spooky, oooky, pumpkin, he, orange, round, oh boy
He rollin' wobble round the patch, working for a tasty snack
Spooky, oooky, pumpkin, I saw for a flight
He'll bite your toes and then you know he's an evil boy tonight
World-tanned, riddle, squashy one you'll never understand
You think you're super spooky, but really, you're just mad
Spooky, oooky, pumpkin, wumbo all you make
Terrorized the neighborhood on this Halloweeny night
World-tanned, riddle, squashy one you'll never understand
You think you're super spooky, but really you're just mad
Spooky, oooky, pumpkin, he, orange, round, oh boy
He rollin' wobble round the patch, working for a tasty snack
Spooky, oooky, pumpkin, wumbo all you make
Terrorized the neighborhood on this Halloweeny night
World-tanned, riddle, squashy one you'll never understand